for decades there has been limited
research about the link between breast
cancer and birth control now a new study
has found the risk is in fact there
Candace Charles joins us live this
morning in The Newsroom with what this
means for women Candace good morning to
you well it means it's important to know
your family history and know your body
regardless of what kind of hormonal
birth control you take because there is
a slightly higher risk of breast cancer
with either one now the extra risk is
about a point two percent over a 15-year
period since the 70s we've known about
the link between breast cancer and
estrogen and progesterone combination
birth controls like the pill but many
women start switching to the single
hormonal progesterone contraceptions
like iuds and the mini pill but the UK
study control excuse me ZK nested case
control study recently published in the
Paul's medicine Journal found the risk
is just the same so containing the
recommendation prevention measures is
suggested
the woman should be knowledgeable of her
breasts if there is something new
present to her doctor
a clinician should examine the rest once
a year and age 40 we start screening
with mammograms
foreign
patients that all types of emotional
contraceptions also protects against
ovarian endometrial cancers now of
course the best thing to do as I
mentioned is to have a conversation with
your doctor and of course there's things
that if folks who do have a history of
family a family history of breast cancer
you want to make sure you talk to your
doctor about that as well we'll have
more details about the study on our
website 8newsnow.com